[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum I hope you're uh
enjoying the episodes I got a lot of
people coming up to me and
you know tell me how much the you know
episodes sometimes mean to them and um
you know it's really nice and hearing
from other even celebrities or my peers
that are are enjoying it and really it's
uh it's awesome if you're here for Paul
Wesley I hope that after this if you
liked it you'll subscribe give the
podcast a chance we've had some great
interviews I'll continue to give you
guys some uh great interviews I hope
um
and uh it's different than other
podcasts we really talk about mental
health and life and all these other
things so if you're listening to Paul
Wesley uh hopefully you'll dig this
you'll subscribe spread the word our
socials Ryan at inside of your pod on
Twitter or or whatever it's called now X
and it's called X and inside of you
podcast on Instagram and Facebook that's
right watch on YouTube you can listen
pretty much anywhere uh if you subscribe
and you write a review that really helps
with the algorithms and all that stuff
so we appreciate that also the inside of
you online store has awesome merch if
you want you know Smallville merch or
whatever tons of stuff on there and
including inside of you
um mugs tumblers and uh the biggest
thing is Patron p-a-t-r-e-o-n
patreon.com inside of you if you want to
join patreon
um become a patron there's so many perks
I do YouTube lives with everyone we I do
some zooms with the top tiers I read out
your names at the end of episodes
um lots of stuff you get uh merch
discounts and no one else stones for the
most part I mean usually you get first
dibs and all that stuff also I'm going
to be doing a lot of cons so check my
link Tree on at the Michael Rosenbaum
Tom Welling and I will be doing some
cons and some evenings with Michael and
Tom anyway uh we got a great episode
today it's uh Paul Wesley Vampire
Diaries he's done a ton of stuff he was
actually in Smallville and uh we had a
good time and uh just I was surprised
how much he's I guess we both grown up
he's just really mature and just carries
himself very confidently and
um earnestly you know he just seems uh
like he's he's got it together yeah and
uh seems happy I like that he's got a
lot to talk about we talk about all of
it thanks for being so open Paul and
hopefully you'll come back and without
further Ado let's just get into it let's
get inside of Paul Wesley it's my point
of view you're listening to inside of
you with Michael Rose
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
hey folks wanted to highlight something
important before today's episode in case
you weren't aware of myself and many of
the guests are on strike alongside sag
after nwga today's episode and any we
air before the strike ends were recorded
before it began so this is just a heads
up in relation to some for the topics we
may discuss if you want more info on the
strike visit
sagafterstrike.org now let's get into it
is it possible that the last time I saw
you it was on the set of Smallville
probably in 2000 two about three or four
so I've been trying to figure that out
myself because I I just can't seem to
Fathom the idea that you and I have not
run into one another at one point or
another I don't know how you were doing
a show I was doing a CW Show but you
were filming in Atlanta I was filming in
Atlanta and I was there and you lived
there pretty much right you know you're
there you became a big star right I was
doing the Smallville thing so it was
probably it makes sense that we wouldn't
see each other I guess so and then you
know you were doing 22 a year as well
right yeah do they still do that yeah I
don't know if they do it anymore but I
feel like we were the last I if they
don't I feel like we were the last wave
of that you know could you imagine doing
that now 22 Episodes a year that's all
right Greg his dog Greg is here he's got
a little separation anxiety like I think
my puppy has and he's really just the
water right now a lot of water but he's
adorable he's Greg Greggy Greggy Greg
why Greg or Greggy if you hear water
licking
um you know what we got him during covid
my ex and I and it was just like he was
a foster puppy and there was three of
them and we gave them kind of ridiculous
names because we did we they were we
thought they would be temporary so we
ended up keeping him and his name just
stuck with him we gave it was two girls
and one boy right and we give them all
boy names I mean it was just like it was
kind of like this arbitrary yeah it was
like Greg Chuck and then my dog my new
puppy's Charlie your new puppy's Charlie
there you go I love human names for dogs
I do too my my yeah my girl is Blanche
yeah I love that I I love it too and
it's all always they're named after
people I love right my grandfather
Charlie uh Blanche is my grandma who is
still alive thank God she lives in Fort
Lauderdale she's she'll be 95. oh wow
yeah you have any grandparents left I
have a grandmother left yeah my grand
sorry man I'm just gonna
get comfortable
um it's real stuff here folks you're
seeing someone get comfortable this is
the real deal you you'll even see that I
had a a blood uh draw if you see the
video yeah
um I I want I'd pretend that I donated
blood like I did something good but I
didn't I just had a blood taken because
I'm you know uh standard standard
standard blood every year blood every
year but also like I feel like I've been
having a ton of allergies my allergies
yeah I just can't deal with it yeah I
constantly have problems so I'm like
doing an allergy blood allergy test as
well and you know whatever ballet stuff
bougie LS you know I'm gonna do that too
Ryan can you make that note to remind me
they do this thing on where they prick
you on the back where the allergies
different things yeah and it's it's real
but like I don't I'm sure it's accurate
but I wanted to also try the blood one
anyway this is really no they do that
with shellfish because they they print
me yeah stay away from crabs like we
only had them in college once right but
uh you know uh but it swelled up a
little with the crabs right so they're
like he's like yeah still steer clear
and there was a couple other things yeah
but yeah it's it's a little Hocus Pocus
but at the same time it's like I want to
find out something's causing this right
something you know something's going on
yeah but now listen you you are so we
met on Smallville I remember you played
my brother yeah Lucas right yeah it's
kind of crazy to me that I played your
brother and I was only on for one
episode yeah I thought you were gonna
come back and then they just left that
story I think you complained about that
on the episode you're like why did and
now he's gone you know at some place but
you know what's weird is like when I
when I originally got that part if
memory serves it's been like two decades
it was supposed to be multi-episode Arc
and I don't know if I just did a shitty
job and they were just like oh let's
stop bringing it back but I I think I
did a pretty good job right so I was
surprised I don't know what happened but
for whatever reason that was it I but I
we talk about this all the time here's
the trend was in the first couple
seasons until they got it together
um is that every show unlike today the
streamers that have Cliffhangers and we
keep they wrap everything up in a nice
bow right and moving on right and it
just irked me right and so that was the
way it was and it evolved and now we've
evolved into this right um but do you
remember anything
at all on that show
oh God because you worked with me you
worked with John Glover who was like our
father that's right yeah and then I I do
remember the director and I remember who
was it uh Beeman Greg Beaman Greg Beeman
and I remember the scene where uh there
was a rain Tower and uh something
happened and I you know I I don't know
there was a shootout and then you
grabbed me and you go uh I'm your
brother and for whatever reason there
was a lot of drama not drama there was
like we were really struggling getting
that moment I don't know if it was like
Greg wasn't happy or you weren't happy I
remember it now yeah I remember it I
remember what it was okay and I
complained about it on the show if you
recall we go out and I go I'm your
brother let's go right but I think what
happens is you come with me and then we
stop at the doors of the car when these
guys were shooting us go look I'm your
brother I'm like dude we wouldn't do
that we have to right we'd go in the car
right right and then we get out of there
and then I'd say that right we can't do
that all right off right all right this
is unrealistic Greg he's like you know
yeah I think we'll remember that day
I won't say who it is but one of the
crew guys pissed their pants they just
had to go to the bathroom in one take
and I heard him going oh God God and
he's like [__] and he he laughed he
pissed himself I uh I don't think I was
privy to that as a guest I was I think
this is a series of regular pissed him
right off on that thing I think it was
uh you used to do this thing all right
this is what I do remember and you're
gonna be like really that's what you
remember and I stole this from you on my
show good so you used a video you used
to do this thing where and you would do
this in like like a very obviously jokey
way and everyone loved it someone would
[__] off no no you would say go [__]
yourself like literally somebody
somebody would say hey Michael can you
uh stand on your mark and be like yeah
go [__] yourself and I just thought it
was so funny and then the crew would do
it with me yeah I'd say hey can you make
sure that yeah [__] yourself let's just
yeah yeah it was a thing we all did it
I became known as the go [__] yourself
in fact there was a it's okay yeah
there's uh there's Greg they even as rap
gifts they gave the crew gfy hats from
me which was and you never called me go
[__] yourself hats I literally stole
that from you did you ever tell anybody
nobody told any I never told anyone yeah
but I'm on a podcast right now telling
the world that I stole go [__] yourself
from you so at least at least I finally
you know it took me some time I'm glad
you did that I remember I remember you
laughing I remember you just I just
thought it was great well I thought it
was fantastic because I just you know
it's like I gotta let it just kind of
relaxes you just go [__] yourself uh I
would say it even when I [__] up
what's the line [__] go [__] yourself
right exactly and it was just it made me
kind of comfortable well it just I think
also and you would know like when you're
a guest star you know when you're a
young guest star and you're coming into
this show that's like nervous you know
it's nerve-wracking and it's like a big
hit show and then you know sometimes
when you have the series regulars who
take themselves too seriously you can
make you even more stressed you don't
want to mess up and then when you have
somebody who's you you know one of the
leads on the show saying go [__]
yourself and everyone's laughing yeah
suddenly you're like okay I can loosen
up a little bit and I can have some fun
yeah I was compelled I felt like oh I've
always been
like an Entertainer in the sense that I
always want to make people ha laugh I
want everyone to have a good time and
it's great because the crew loves you
and everybody's laughing all the time
right but the converse to that is you're
exhausted you're just giving everything
by half the day you're you just want to
like right and then you ask yourself why
do I do that and then you go home and
you're exhausted it's a clown that you
know you painted smile and you go right
oh my God I'm a Loser yeah it's funny I
I often you know because it's such a
grind uh doing you know a show for so
long and I I remember like there were
days where people I just got very you
know I did the opposite I just wouldn't
I just wouldn't interact I was just so
tired and so exhausted I would do my job
say my lines I always knew what I was I
always knew what I was doing I always
knew my lines but I didn't interact as
much and that's something I regret I
wish I was a little bit more like you
know what we're all here we're all
family and and I didn't take it as
seriously as I did that's the one thing
that I kind of on the whole run of
yeah well that's understandable I mean
you know I think there's only so much
you can do there's days where I walked
in I just you know wasn't a good mood
and they're like hey and I go what's
going on man and just kind of my head or
whatever and that's called Humanity yeah
you know I mean we have bad days that's
why when I hear things like
um
you know I I so-and-so he's an [__]
and I'm like right and they're like John
and I'm like why right my friends
friends girlfriend
cousin saw him at some screening and she
went up to him says hey I'm a big fan I
like you and then he was just kind of
like oh thanks and just kind of walked
up kind of stand off right do you ever
think that someone's having not a great
day or right someone died or right I
don't always I give the benefit to look
if you hear it consistently like this
guy's an answer that guy is right then
the truth kind of follows right you know
it's sort of like uh it's obvious but
right I wouldn't feel guilty I think a
lot of actors do that whether they just
want to get on do their work yeah
they're not there to like you know
entertain they're there to do the work
yeah and that's that's okay yeah you
know as long as you're not Chris I'm not
a Christian bailing on right right I'm
not always like that but I did I did
sort of get that sort of like oh man I
was just like by season
eight you're just like dude I can't oh
yeah what the what the [__] yeah with
the following you had because it was way
bigger than Smallville right Vampire
Diaries was just like holy [__] right
you had that whole I mean that fandom is
insane right a good way like they're
just so supportive so and uh you know
when you're first doing the show it's
exciting you have a hit yeah but has
there ever come a time where you know
you're young and you're like maybe we're
cocky maybe we think you know you know
this is cheesy or this is this right can
we be more serious can't we and you sort
of go in that phase of like I just want
to do something else I want to do oh
totally oh absolutely I really do
absolutely yeah I mean I mean when
you're by season three or so you're
going oh [__] you know I need to do some
other stuff I mean I I started to like
really get into the whole like I need to
um you know be a thespian and so I
started to do like New York theater yeah
that was my thing during Hiatus I was
just like going off and doing like off
bro obscure Broadway how did you have
the the energy to do that I think I had
the energy younger first of all I was
younger but also it's just sort of
um
you're so you know how it is look I'm
not knocking the show but at the end of
the day you're doing a one hour you know
uh CW drama
inside he was brought to you by Factor
meals I love these guys Ryan I love
Factor meals do you know how much time I
save not cooking
and that I'm getting delicious healthy
meals to my door and I get to choose
what I want every week crazy and it's so
much cheaper than the crap that I pay
for in the delivery service and all this
stuff that's never healthy you know what
you're getting with the busy fall season
just around the corner you might be
looking for wholesome convenient meals
for jam-packed days Factor America's
number one ready to eat meal kit can
help you fuel up fast with Chef prepared
dietitian approved ready to eat meals
delivered straight to your door you'll
save time eat well and stay on track
with your healthy lifestyle refresh your
Healthy Habits without missing a beat
choose from 34 plus weekly flavored
packed dietitian approved meals ready to
eat in two minutes level up with Gourmet
plus options prepared to Perfection by
chefs and ready to eat in record time
treat yourself to upscale meals with
premium ingredients like broccolini
leeks truffle butter and asparagus too
busy running round during the day to
think about lunch keep your energy up
with lunch to go effortless wholesome
meals like grain bowls and salad Toppers
that are ready to eat when you're on the
go no microwave required and I know you
folks out there looking for calorie
conscious options ahead of your busy
season well uh try delicious dietitian
approve calorie smart meals with around
or less than 550 calories per serving
and I'll tell you the snack Supply Ryan
you get an assortment of 45 plus add-ons
breakfast items like apple cinnamon
pancakes bacon and cheddar egg bites and
potato bacon and egg breakfast skillet
or for an easy Wellness boost try
refreshing beverage options like cold
pressed juices shakes and smoothies
ah just doesn't end this August get
factor and enjoy eating well without the
hassle simply choose your meals and
enjoy fresh flavor-packed meals
delivered to your door ready in just two
minutes no prep No Mess head to
factormeels.com
inside 50 and use code inside 50 to get
50 percent off that's code inside 50 at
factormeals.com inside 50 to get 50 off
this show is sponsored by betterhelp
betterhelp has been with me for a long
time and I think I know why because this
uh this podcast deals with a lot of
mental health
um people talking about their anxiety
and depressions and uh we're all
imperfect we're all flawed and that's
the beautiful thing about life and
sometimes we get in ruts sometimes
um our path isn't as clear that's in
front of us we're not sure what we're
going to do we can't find purpose this
is where better help comes in and it's
so important whether you're dealing with
decisions around your career your
relationships or anything else therapy
helps you stay connected to what you
really want while you navigate life so
you can move forward with confidence and
excitement trusting yourself to make
decisions that align with your values is
like anything the more you practice it
the easier it gets the great thing about
this is the stigma is going away folks
so you know my dad he doesn't go to
therapy and you know I've been talking
to him I'm like listen everybody so many
people do this you're not the only
person who gets in ruts you know when we
lost my sister
um I finally got him into therapy and um
it's just important to know you're not
alone you're just not alone and with
better help you can get your therapist
online if you don't like your therapist
you change it like that it's so easy
it's so much more affordable than
looking up some therapist that you don't
know and going uh yeah and it costs you
so much money to go in there look if
you're thinking of starting therapy give
better help a try it's entirely online
it's convenient flexible and suited to
your schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire it's so so quick and get
matched with a licensed therapist switch
therapist anytime for no additional
charge period it's entirely online so
it's convenient flexible and suited to
your schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire it takes seconds and get
matched with a licensed therapist switch
therapist anytime for no additional
charge let therapy be your map with
better help visit betterhelp.com inside
today to get 10 off your first month
that's better her help
h-e-l-p.com slash inside let therapy be
your map with better help visit
betterhelp.com inside today to get 10
off your first month that's ten percent
off your first month better help
h-e-l-p.com slash inside
yeah so by season three you started
feeling like you know uh you know I want
to do other things I need to be
challenged more I need to yeah you know
mix it up I don't want to be just this
guy well you don't want to be you don't
want to be Typecast you know and and
also you're like okay uh you know I have
this pop culture Fame to a degree but am
I respected and I want to be respected
by you know fellow actors and so you're
you know you're striving to do different
kinds of things and you know but that's
natural I think everybody you know you
always want to prove yourself always I
mean you always want to challenge
yourself prove yourself that I'm not
just this guy I could do a lot of other
stuff I studied theater right I do
off-broads I'm not just that and it's
more like
you're like we're thinking too much yeah
yeah well I do think like for example
man like it's it's this very interesting
thing where you know there is like this
Run Lola Run thing where it's like you
know I I remember I auditioned for The
Vampire Diaries they said you know uh
you're not right for the part I said
okay cool different role and I went and
tested for like two other shows that
were very mature very adult you know it
would have put me in a completely
different category right and and and but
then vampires called and suddenly I got
that part and I always think to myself
like what if I'd gotten one of the other
roles it's funny how like it's just you
you sort of whatever you get cast in
that makes you sort of you know you
become known for that right and so it's
this funny thing where it's like they're
you know uh what's his name uh Pedro
Pascal is a great example he screen
tested for The Vampire Diaries spin-off
uh the originals and he didn't get the
part and now he's on and by the way he's
a wonderful actor I love that I love it
and now he's on this is us not The Last
of Us last they should combine those
it's a spin-off of This Is Us yeah yeah
um but uh it's uh no but he was great on
narcos and now he's on on that show but
they just turned that way but it's funny
how I think to myself like what if Pedro
Pascal got he got the Vampire Diaries
spin-off you know and it's just like
it's so you're always thinking to
yourself like did I make the right
decision and I am very happy with my
decision I think it's incredible to you
know but it's it's you're as a young
actor you're always questioning yeah no
I agree I I think that it's funny how
the and maybe it's different now because
I think you know film is kind of murder
you know film urges in the TV vice versa
and you can do whatever you want now
anybody cares right but there's this
sort of this um there's this there was
this mentality and maybe there is still
that mentality where for some reason
they think you know if you have a Smash
Hit like this is us and great actors I
have friends on that show
but if someone's in Vampire Diaries or
Smallville or some other show that have
happens to be on a different network CW
or superhero or whatever yeah
they don't think some of these actors
aren't capable of doing what those guys
are doing right like right they
does that make sense of course yeah it's
just to me it's like
you know just because we're on a show
that deals with all this you know
whatever right it doesn't mean we don't
have the chops right if we were on a
different show with the writing and
directing and the creating and
everything um it'd just be just as good
of course because you're only as good as
the writing and the production of course
yeah it doesn't matter how good of an
actor you are if you're a great actor
and you're on on some okay show or some
fluffy show or whatever the show and I'm
not saying vampire or smash that but you
know the CW thing you know it doesn't
mean you don't have the chops look at
Malcolm in the Middle and look at
[__] Cranston yeah of course [__]
genius I got a great uh Brian Cranston
uh he's a he's a buddy of mine so so
Brian uh so I was the lead of this show
this is before the vampires leave this
ABC Family show called wolf a fallen
yeah yeah and and it was this uh show
about this uh it was it was a great
miniseries about like this guy it was
based on a book uh this boy who's um
young kid who's like a fallen angel
um and he figures out that he's actually
like the son of the devil and it was
going to be this huge stunt casting
thing at the end of uh episode five
where we reveal the devil
um Lucifer and they were like we're
gonna guess what amazing we're gonna
cast went amazing and I was waiting I
was waiting waiting waiting for who they
were going to cast and suddenly they're
like we got the dad from Malcolm in the
Middle and I was like wait what what do
you mean you got that I was like the dad
from Malcolm in the Middle how is he
gonna play Lucifer like I don't see how
this is gonna work he's he's it's comedy
and Brian came on the show and I
remember being like I don't know that
Brian can play the devil
um because I only knew him from Malcolm
in the Middle Of course goofy his pants
off all the time right over the top and
I was like I don't see you so anyway
Brian of course nailed it and was
brilliant because he's Brian
um and then he went on to get Breaking
Bad
um and then went on to then you know be
who he is today
um but it's this funny even eye even I
was guilty of of of judging Brian
Cranston who's you know arguably one of
the greatest actors uh right now period
um that's working and and and I was
judging him based on Malcolm in the
Middle see you know we all do it yeah
yeah you know I'm sure they would say
this I I don't know if they'd say it
because I have hair
I mean but they say oh Lex Luthor's
playing this role I don't think they
would do you
what now now
uh a completely different person
you are completely different from Lex
Luthor that is true
I think enough time has passed too he's
looking right Ryan tell me what I want
to hear yeah tell me what I want to hear
um let's talk about this so you come
from a Polish family yeah
I had no idea I knew nothing about you I
started looking I'm like you speak
Polish yeah yeah I mean fluidly without
without skipping a beep do you talk to
your parents so yes the answer is yes
when I was younger that was my first
language because my parents didn't
really speak English very well and my
grandparents only spoke polish so that
was it growing up I was I was living
there for a short time when I was a kid
back and forth going there all the time
um and then you know as you get older
you're you move out of your parents
house you start speaking English you
know exclusively and suddenly you start
speaking English with your parents my
parents are very thick accents but now
it doesn't come as easily to me anymore
I'm fluent I understand everything but I
have to search for Words my accent is
still really good it's there but I've
lost that that sort of natural Rhythm
that I always had as a child because it
drives me crazy drive them crazy drives
me crazy drives them crazy I also my
dream is to get cast in a like a Polish
role so that I and so that I it forces
me to to go back get back in the group
Stella did it who did it Stella Stella
Stella Got Her Groove Back yeah it took
me a minute I was gonna let you find it
um so if I I mean you probably hate to
do it but like you just start talking to
me in Polish uh it's polish right in
Polish yeah yeah
[Music]
um
uh
I a dog is P.S PS my puppy PS is all
over the place exactly that's why that's
why we got it from piss yes yeah no yes
but yeah I love that can you do other
accents
um like Borat you can do Borat nice I
can do Borat I like him yeah that's good
uh could you do pretty much any accent
if you were Absolute German no well it's
funny because my girlfriend is
um German slash Brazilian but she speaks
fluent German my grandfather spoke
fluent German but anyway that's her
first language is I mean I guess it's
like Portuguese German but German is
such a specific language
um it's terrifying first of all
um and everything sounds like I'd smoke
yeah exactly exactly yeah exactly it's
like it's like that you literally are if
you're in Germany you just feel like
you're in trouble all the time but maybe
that's just me and my my polish Roots
I'm just uh it's in ingrained in My DNA
to be terrified of Germans yeah well
they took over Poland right well that
how much you so I kind of relate that
whole thing um but you know
um yeah I have a lot of German friends
and you know they don't want to hurt me
yeah but yeah but I I know a little
German but you know it's
means I I have no I [__] my pants I okay
well that's good because I'm gonna need
that one of these you're gonna tell your
girlfriend
that's disgusting
nine nine but isn't treza [__] [__]
I'm tired okay I know you know all this
uh when I did this the heart we talk
about I did a horrible movie in Germany
a year so many years ago before small
what's it called
yeah it's called Rave Macbeth Rave
well here's why it got so it was so bad
it was Macbeth in a rave okay we had
Kirk balls from Reservoir Dogs the guy
that got his ear cut off uh-huh okay
sure yeah really great actor okay but we
had to redo
all the audio
we had to do ADR for the entire they
lost it and they just like literally
lost the cassette tape well it was gone
and they're completely damaged okay and
we had to Loop the whole I was miserable
for four days it was the lead all my
dialogue it looks like [__] when I
scream
or whatever or vice versa yeah it's it's
it's yeah that's how I learned right a
guy named Nico who picked me up Michael
what uh Guten Morgen I'm like Morgan
Nico how do I say I [__] my pants
Michael how do you want to know these
things although that's the first thing
you ask you're like I'm an American
pants that's you need useful you know
useful communication yeah but I know
like cops and I have a headache I know
now Heights mouth shut your mouth
uh you know yeah it's like that right
um but yeah I I agree it's so funny too
because
my whole life I was always doing
impressions and I was always doing
watching movies like because I never
went to a high school dance or anything
I always stuck in my room and copied
movies from one VCR to another VCR never
went out I mean I was not a popular guy
and I just always thought I would use
these I use them in real life with my
friends joke and fun but I've never
gotten a role what's up with that where
I have to do some accent except uh
whatever one role I had to do like a
Southern accent Midnight in the Garden
of Good and Evil and I did a little
something for this show Breaking In
where I just kind of had this thing man
a little makani in a way but it wasn't
hmm it's like all right man here's one
whatever but um not not a ton oh yeah I
think anybody could do mcconnie he can't
think give me one Ryan
uh all right all right all right all
right how about you what's that uh uh
they just oh I just keep getting older
they just stay the same age that's what
I like about these freshman girls that's
right what is that what is that what is
that from they stay the same dazed and
confused confused that's right hey we
want to get rid of these little dorks
and hang out with me man I don't know I
don't do my Connie
this message is sponsored by discover
did you know you could reduce the number
of unwanted calls and emails with online
privacy protection the latest Innovation
from discover discover will help
regularly remove your personal info like
your name and address from 10 popular
people search websites that could sell
your data and they'll do it for free
activate in the Discover app see terms
and learn more at discover.com online
privacy protection but
um so you got you you were raised in New
Jersey yeah were your parents like they
wanted you to become an actor no or was
it completely like what are you doing I
think it's funny I was reading that book
uh out what is that Malcolm Gladwell
book where he keeps talking about like
time and a place and you got to be lucky
because you're in you know a lot of
times like you know he was talking about
like Bill Gates and his success because
he had a computer in his school and it
was like a dime a needle and a haystack
of a computer in school at that time I
think it's one of those things where I
don't think I would have been an actor
if I didn't grow up in close proximity
of New York City I grew up 45 minutes
outside of New York City and I don't
think I would have been an actor unless
I got kicked off the hockey team which I
did got kicked off the hockey team I was
bored out of my mind I had nothing to do
why did you get kicked off fighting
isn't that we supposed to do in hockey
that's what I play but like fighting
with a coach oh yeah yeah that's not
yeah I started doing theater in high
school and I fell in love with it man I
just thought it was so great and I told
my parents I loved it and then you know
I started doing these acting classes in
the city because it was right there and
agent saw me and said do you want to
audition for that fast boom and then I
got a soap opera and then hiding light
yeah yeah no my first one was another
world and I was so excited I signed a
serious regular contract and then it got
canceled uh three months later uh which
was a disaster after after being the
longest show all it took was me getting
on the show it was literally by the way
it was the longest show in the history
of Television it's another world yeah it
started on radio and it moved into a
transition from Radio into television
and then I get on the show and it gets
canceled so what's the story but it's a
blessing in disguise it's a blessing in
disguise because then guiding lights on
me they through me on their show do you
remember the theme song for guiding line
I have no idea or another world no it
wasn't a whole new world actually may
have been that that was a movie but but
so so then you did Guiding Light and
then yeah so you dropped out of high
school college Rutgers you went to
Russia well yeah I was in high school
doing Guiding Light and I but I and I
barely graduated then I went to Rutgers
for like a semester thinking oh well
this acting thing isn't going anywhere
which is what we all do and then I was
like because my dad is you know he's a
computer engineer my mom's you know a
psychologist and I was my sister's a
lawyer like everyone's pretty academic
right and so here I am like goofing off
doing some soap opera and I thought this
isn't Gonna Last but then it just kept I
kept doing stuff kept working and then I
dropped out of Rutgers thinking I'll
just go back I'll do this for another
year and then I'll go back to school and
get a real job and then I just never
went back and here I am with Greg in
Laurel Canyon oh Greg you know let's not
get his attention yeah you're right by
the way he's doing well he's
he's good he just needs to like
understand the environment that he's in
he's like okay we're gonna sit here for
a little yeah take some my puppy is just
driving me crazy 16 days I don't know
when this will air but 16 days and it's
like take him out 25 minutes every 25
minutes every you know regulating his
water intake yeah and and he'll come
right back in the house after pee look
at me and just pass what's the I don't
know I tell you what I did with the Bell
the crew no the crate training I am he's
in a crate and I leave for an hour shits
in the crate after he's already [__]
interesting every time I leave
interesting so I don't know what to do
I'm you know what I'm doing I'm sending
him away really to a boarding school for
six days or seven days or maybe two
weeks okay yeah he has to get some more
shots and then I'm gonna do that I'm
gonna have to just make sure you pick a
good one oh yeah this one's highly
recommended my friends are we deal with
a lot of rescues okay my friend has a
rescue Shira
um animal rescue mission and yeah all
right okay and I know you're involved
with the Humane Society you've been
raising money for years yeah yeah I have
that's amazing thanks man yeah I'm a
huge animal rights Advocate and now you
know like even just rescuing Greg
um who was you know left in some like
the middle of the desert or whatever
some crazy as all these puppies are and
uh rescuing him just made me even more
empathetic and so yeah I've been working
with um with organizations uh a ton uh
yeah yeah I just find animals to be in
many ways so much more interesting than
humans like they're so funny Greg is my
dog like he will sometimes surprise me
so much with his intelligence other
times I think he's I'm like how do you
not know this yeah and then other times
he just he just I Marvel at his at his
had his mind you know and I just find
animals to be so interesting and yeah so
they are and they're wonderful you just
look at you know my dog was bringing
being brought to a kill shelter and this
rescue intervened and stopped and they
were called La Pets Alive okay all the
rescue and just this old guy named John
and I happened to walk into a some pet
store and where I never would go because
my friend wanted to go and I saw this
little puppy in a wow cage and I go uh I
gotta take him and I don't know what the
[__] I was thinking right it's but I
love him yeah and it's but you know I
good for people who are a rescuing
animals I mean you know I I we can get
into that all day but you know you so
you work closely with Humane Society
you're you're a vegan yeah is that hard
yeah that's gotta be hard if you've got
a hamburger right now would you throw up
I haven't had a hamburger I it's funny
not really first of all no I would throw
up um but I also haven't I didn't eat
hamburgers when I was a kid so it's like
it's more a Polish sausage well that I
did there you go it's irresistible but
what it's about what's it about you know
it's just like I um
yeah I don't I don't crave meat I don't
crave meat I will say when I'm traveling
it's a pain in the ass yeah you know
it's and then you end up eating like
[__] so I think it's just like you know
and then and then you know there's
moments where you slip up and you know
it's like you're plant-based because you
know you eat something you don't even
know what it is and then you're like oh
[__] and then you know it but I haven't
had you know any type I wasn't eating
beef for I haven't eaten beef in 15
years man I just don't even know yeah I
don't even think about it I think
honestly I would probably the thing is
I'm a thin guy so are you but like I
know that if I stop eating meat I'm
gonna get really bored with my meals I
mean I can go impossible burger right
right but there's there's a lot of stuff
in there that kind of is more a lot of
stuff that's not great right in there
too it's it's it's this uh I don't
really eat I I eat that's not true I eat
some impossible burgers and Beyond
Burgers once in a while but I think it's
more like I'd rather have the the [__]
the stuff whatever stuff is in there
than some of the [__] that goes on in
the middle oh yeah you know so yeah yeah
I know I understand that I'm trying I
just yeah my problem is and I got to
stop this like if I was smoking a little
bit and I stopped that it's like 23 days
now I'm done I'm [__] done this time
that's it
smoking dude I mean that's the worst
thing in the world it's the worst thing
in the world I I [__] love smoking oh
I don't smoke I don't smoke but I enjoy
the the the feeling I enjoy the the
habit I love the rich I know going down
go outside now I'm gonna have a smoke
I know you smell like [__] and then I'm
trying to get Nicorette as a sponsor
because honestly Scott calm was on the
podcast afterwards we went in the back
and I had to smoke yeah and you don't
smoke he's like no no I quit many years
ago yeah like I just can't do it I can't
kick it up yeah I don't know why I've
been so stressed I'm smoking
and he goes
he literally had this right here the
secret thing yeah and the Lawson just
low dose two milligrams I just went and
he put him on the table he goes take
these really and now since I took the
first one really not touch the cigarette
wow they texted him yesterday and told
him since you left me I have not smoked
a cigarette that's amazing I wanted what
I want to do is like stop eating chips
at night yeah eat pretzels yeah and all
this [__] and then I'm like you know and
then like it's okay how about I'm gonna
have a fruit salad before I go to bed
they're like no the fruits are really
hard it gives you all this energy I'm
like oh so I can't even have fruits and
I just get so upset and the thought of
like I don't know I just got to stop
because of Health it helps I don't have
health reason.com wood but I'm gonna
have them I just think about like how do
I not want to die and then like the the
the the thought of just not being able
to use my lungs by the way I smoked for
years and like just the thought of it is
what is enough for me yeah you know what
I mean yeah [__] I mean you and you have
kids no I don't kids you don't have two
dogs
really yeah I don't care I don't have
kids either thank God I'm not for you
for me thank God you don't have kids you
have kids no you have kids no just dogs
yeah and listen right away I don't know
why I thought you had kids
no no kids I mean wow I once got a girl
pregnant right
but she didn't have a kid right her
choice right right no but that's much
different yes um yeah wow okay so you're
not a kid's guy no I love kids do you
want to have kids you know it's nice to
see a cute kid and one of my friends
kids and I play with him for 20 minutes
and I go all right do you want to have
kids no I don't think so really I'm 50.
I'm I'm I could barely deal with a pup
if you saw the text messages to my
friends right I can't do it I gotta send
him back right he got all the shots I'll
take care of whatever I'll find him a
family this is this is too hard the
other two dogs were easy and they're
like just calm down and everybody knows
everything about dogs like listen have
you tried this I'm like [__] you yes
I've tried that have you taken him out
every hour every 25 minutes and they go
on everybody's a Monday Morning
Quarterback so whatever right but anyway
back to you yeah so uh you start acting
you do Guiding Light all these things
they start happening you move out to LA
hmm
kind of kind not really what do you mean
well I didn't I never wanted to leave
New York I got a New York City I got a
little place in New York City and then I
got a pilot that took me to Vancouver
and I was out in Vancouver and then my
agent said why don't you come to La for
a month and I was like all right I went
to LA for the pilot season [__] you
know how that is and I was out in LA and
I hated it I just hated and I kept
telling myself okay two more weeks
another week I got a pile it I ended up
getting some show it shot in La I was
miserable and then I just hated La for
years man and now I just think it's the
greatest that's what happened to me I
moved from New York I said I'll never
leave New York I moved out there to do a
show it wasn't a great show yeah and um
I said I was miserable I haven't found I
didn't find my group yet people I was
hanging around some folks I shouldn't
hang out with I was just young and
stupid and just trying to figure it out
and the glitz and glamor of Hollywood
and you know I didn't have much money
and all a sudden after I started to get
the right people the friends the things
the playing softball playing doing fun
things
I never want to go back to New York ever
yeah I never want to be in that
miserable cold again yeah I never want
to be in the miserable heat with the
sorry if you're New Yorkers I'm I'm a
born New Yorker my whole family's from
New York I like to visit for a couple
days maybe see a show but yeah it's
funny you know I I I feel it's funny
because I'm getting a place in New York
as we speak but I I I my family's there
I can go to New York like I love Landing
in New York and being there for the
first 24 hours and then it just drains
me oh yeah
um La I live on the west side and I just
what I love but I love the culture in
New York and I love being able to see my
family that's the reason I'm getting a
place there and you know it's like it's
just fun to get on a skateboard or bike
or something and just like you know run
around the city and stop by various
spots but man the west side for me is
where it's at like just the hiking
hiking with my dog surfing riding my
motorcycles I just love I love me nature
man I crave that [__] I envy you I
always talk about this I'm sort of like
a Hermit man I I look I like playing ice
hockey on Mondays tennis on Tuesdays
softball an occasional hike
but I'm not a big nature guy
I think because partly I'm colorblind
and everything's kind of muted nothing
looks as pretty as everyone thinks you
know what colors do you see just like
red green like I can't differentiate
you're kidding you know traffic lights
look white when I and it's funny because
I ask my cousin who's colorblind my
brother I'm like what color do you see
in a traffic like he goes well the red
and the yellow kind of merge if they
weren't in order I wouldn't know so you
don't really know what red and yellow is
I kind I could see a real red angle
that's red sometimes people say well
it's more of an orange but yeah oh
that's actually it but I mess up colors
all the time but uh yeah it's just uh
you know I'll say what color do you see
a traffic light and they go white that's
what I see right you know I've taken all
those colorblind tests my friend Tom
still thinks he I think he [__] with me
but he's always like you're not
colorblind right what are you talking
about I mean I I don't know if it's the
colors I just
um I don't I never get it sounds I hate
myself for like talking about this in
this way but like I never get like bored
when I'm like walking with my dog and
there's like trees and like little
sounds and birds and [__] I'm always
like and it sounds so lame and maybe no
not lame but I'm just like I don't give
a [__] about anything I don't care I'm
just like this it's your time yeah dog's
time I love it man what movie is that
from you're absolutely right Mr Spicoli
it is our time oh it's Johnson it's
Ferris Bueller no Spicoli Fast Times
yeah yeah
Spicoli Sean Penn right yeah which he
doesn't like to talk about he doesn't
like to you know whatever he he he's the
guy that originated that sort of West
Side Surfer whoa yeah what's up bro
that's he's the guy that like tasty
waves yeah he was awesome you knock when
you enter Curtis and Trey yeah I love
that
um all right so I like that I like that
you know you love L.A now I still love
New York you have that ability to do
that did so you started getting pilots
and stuff do you remember the audition
for Vampire Diaries oh dude it was hell
how many auditions dude I'm not
exaggerating I've been doing this for a
while I've done a ton of you know TV
pilots and it's always stressful you
know how that [__] is screen testing and
doing the network in the studio like
crap it's brutal this was the worst
experience of my life I mean I read for
Ian Somerhalder's role first and I got a
call back uh then they then I didn't
hear from them I told you I tested for
some other shows and then they I get a
frantic phone call they've done three
rounds of testing they can't find
anybody for this roll of Stefan the
younger brother uh they'll bring you in
uh read for it I went and read for it
they said great you're testing the next
day I went back I went and I showed up
and because it started shooting in a
week they were testing I think 14 guys
I'm not exaggerating they were all there
all there it was uh uh uh they flew two
out from Australia one ounce from New
Zealand a few out from England anybody
that you would know oh yeah uh who
because I can name so many people that I
tested with that got the roles that I
didn't it's so funny because I actually
like at the time was pretty oblivious to
it but I remember Julie pleck who was a
co-creator of the show ended up telling
me one day all the actors that read from
my part and it was this like incredible
list of you know uh uh you know
a-listers and all these people and
anyway so I go in there and I swear it
was like I I mean it was like uh you
know you'd go in you'd read for it once
then they'd be like okay wait outside
then they'd come out with like a
clipboard and they'd be like you go home
and then some guy would be go home with
his bags and then they'd go and okay
read again and they would come out okay
you two go home boom those guys and it
like it was like this like I felt like I
was on Survivor and it was like dwindled
down and suddenly it was down to like me
and just like one dude and um and then
there was the final I mean I think I
read for it like six or seven times the
one good thing about that is that there
was no network it was just studio and
then they decided to film the audition
and send it to the network
um because they just couldn't they had
to get um you know everyone uh to
Vancouver to shoot but I'll tell you I
uh I had a real specific approach which
was Nina who was already cast as the
lead girl was there
and everybody in uh in that audition uh
room during that process was kissing her
ass because she was in the hallways and
she was like everyone was like going up
to her and saying hi and kissing her ass
thinking you know if they ask her who
did you like you know maybe she'll like
me and I was like [__] that I'm not
gonna look her in the eye and I'm also
not going to introduce myself and I'm
not gonna I'm just gonna sit in the
corner because not because I was trying
to be rude but because in the scene we
were supposed to not know who one
another supposed to be a mystery we were
supposed to meet I know it's very
methodical [__] you it works we were
supposed to meet in uh in that exact
moment and I thought well [__] that I
want our moment to be really special I
want her to get to know me in that
moment and Ira and and Nina remembers
this and I just remember her like
looking over at me wanting to say hi to
me and introduce herself and I just
turned away and I and I think she
thought initially like who the [__] does
this guy think he is but anyway I went
in there and I just remember our
audition the audition in and the first
time we ever met in real life was
actually in that audition room and I and
it was just a very magical moment and I
felt it wow she felt it and I know all
those Studio Executives felt it and I
think that's what landed me the part
actually and then afterwards you say you
know that I was doing this for yeah of
course and she was like and she and she
talks about it in in interviews she even
says like Paul was so dismissive and
rude and I didn't know what to make of
it but then in the in the in the
audition it totally worked wow but then
you left her wondering God is he gonna
be an [__] and son right I don't know
and then surprise I was surprised I'm
not talking to anybody I'm in my head
that was later on in the show right
um how soon after a how soon after did
you know I think we have a hit on our
hands or B did you and and B did you
ever think
is your job in Jeopardy do you think
you're gonna get fired oh dude I thought
I was gonna get fired for the first
three to four years of of of you know
doing the show why because they actually
made us so it was actually kind of
something that they did that was
somewhat unfair so a lot of young kids
on the show a lot of party kids a lot of
like you know without you know everyone
was in their like early 20s you know and
they're all just like going out and
getting hammered and you know screwing
around with each other yeah and and and
so the first you know Season you know
was like a lot of people were showing up
to work late a lot of like you know
things of that nature and I wasn't man I
was taking this [__] so seriously I was
literally sitting at home studying my
lines and trying to and working out and
getting in shape for the role and all
that crap but they said from the
beginning you know they brought us all
in and they said just so you guys know
you're all Expendable every one of you
every yeah every single one of you this
isn't the this isn't the the the my
character's name was Stefan this isn't
the step often Diaries this isn't the
Elena Diaries this isn't the you know
this is the Vampire Diaries and any one
of you can go and they they and so I was
we were all petrified worst thing to do
yeah and it really put this back what
they do though yeah it is they want you
not to we don't know if the show's gonna
get picked up yeah well what do you mean
the numbers are outraged yeah I don't
know yeah hey renegotiations exactly
this means I'm a part of an integral
part of so I'll make some more money
well this show is paying for a lot of
our shows that are failing so what are
you talking about right in the real
world you part of a business and you
know you're an integral part yeah
hopefully it doesn't always happen but
yeah that's that's kind of yeah yeah no
I mean it it was a way and I will say it
worked because people started to not to
not show up late Etc but for myself I
was a little bit like man like you know
I I was already taking it very seriously
but in any case so yes I always felt
like I was going to get fired um as far
as the question you know did I know we
had a hit like this was before Twitter
and Instagram and all this crap too you
don't know yeah you know so it's not
like you can like go on and see that
it's a trending you know show or
whatever the hell
um and so I just remember being like I
guess people are watching this I don't
know and you know with the
um overnight ratings and all that like
you never know you hear about the
ratings like a few days later but I
remember just this very distinct
um I was moment I was in uh Atlanta and
the pilot or the season it just started
airing and
um I just remember I was staying at like
the W Hotel for some bizarre reason
and I walked down the lobby and someone
goes oh you're the guy from the vampires
and I just remember being like oh wow no
way you watched the show I was so
excited it was my first time getting
recognized from the show and then I go
to the and I was super happy and I go
down to the valet and the ballet is like
you're the guy from the Barrett and then
I pulled up to some other places because
you're the guy and I went oh [__] like
five people just recognized me like
within the span of like seven minutes
and I thought okay maybe maybe if uh
people are watching this and then after
that that was that was when I knew we
had a hit that's that's amazing you know
my reality was then
was I always felt like the poor me but I
always felt like
um I just wasn't important I wasn't
anybody I wasn't and so when I started
getting recognized that people came up
to me I felt like oh wow
I am somebody right I'm somebody I'm
someone yeah they notice me someone
notices me yeah it was kind of a and you
had such a distinct because you shaved
your head yeah you know you commit it's
not like you put a uh one of those no
thank God by the way I begged for them
and you look great with a shaved head
thank you I I know what I mean so but
thank thank you well because it could
have gone South you could have just
shaved it because everybody had to look
good right right I was always scared I
was gonna get fired I've told this story
before but like I always felt like
you know I have a bump on the back of my
head I'm not as good looking as the
other cast members I'm kind of awkward
I'm like the I don't know I'm not a
natural I thought you were the best
thing in the show oh thank you well
thanks for saying that no I really feel
that way but I think a lot of people
felt that way you know what's funny I I
didn't hear that until I think really
the show ended really I mean I never I
heard oh you're great you're like but I
I it was almost like years after the
show it now it starts to
I I hear it more like people at
conventions and people that are but I
didn't hear that you're you're the best
I remember I remember like a very
specific
I I I I I don't remember I look it's
been a while but I just remember like
having that sort of like impression when
I got on the show I was like oh he's
like the the you know with all due
respect to all the other cats I was like
he's like the interesting like I thought
your choices were interesting your style
was interesting things you were doing
were interesting it was like much less
sort of CW right and it was a little
more sort of like
um a different approach which I which I
really respected thank you yeah you know
honestly I think a lot of that has to do
with also the writing you know giving me
things that are interesting right
different scenes with more mature people
right but look at the end of the day yes
9 out of ten girls favorite characters
yeah that's the one of course cool chick
yeah that's like hey yeah freaking Lex
Luthor freak which I love yeah it's
funny because I on my show I mean it's
it's you know it was like uh everyone
loved the bad boy everyone loved uh
Damon and and then there's like the
occasional like I like Stefan and in the
back in the back like you know yeah
everyone she gets booed and there's
Tomatoes did you uh when did you really
start becoming close friends with Ian
was it immediate yeah it was pretty
immediate Ian and I uh uh are like we're
totally different human beings I mean
like you could not we are like oil and
vinegar in that sense and I think I
think but that that worked well for us
in a yin and yang way it worked great
for our on-screen chemistry it worked
great for sort of having the two
brothers being Polar Opposites yin and
yang energy and we just really kind of
understood immediately that we would
work well together and that we could
create a really good uh dramatic uh
television series with our different
personalities and I think that lended
itself lends itself to our relationship
off screen which we sort of are very
similar now we have a business together
and it's like you know Brothers Bond
Bourbon Brothers Bond bourbon can they
get that in stores anywhere anywhere
Amazon yeah actually anywhere yeah
Brothers Bond Bourbon and it's doing
well it's doing a straight bourbon
whiskey yeah we have we have uh you can
get Brothers bun I'm gonna get a bottle
you should I am I'm gonna buy one you
can literally go down to Whole Foods and
grab a bottle
um how about the uh Country Store
uh maybe they might have it I don't know
so it's it's some of the some of the
smaller shops it's like it's like hit or
miss but uh we're big online and um more
more so uh in getting more and more into
like restaurants and bars and stuff but
this uh like you know the business that
we started it's doing really well and
it's like we approach it completely
differently and that's what's great
about it we have a complete yin and yang
approach Ian's like oh my God optimism
positive positive and I'm like here's
the worst case scenario and which is
most likely to happen yeah this is you
know this is we're all gonna you know
we're gonna go bankrupt and then so we
we meet in the middle you know I do that
with my friend Tom we're doing some kind
of product I won't say what it is yet
but we just met the guy who's the
manufacturer and I'm like so uh uh he's
like going it's easy you just we you buy
this many at this month they have it's
all it's all done oh and I'm like all
right Insurance wise right how does this
work right I'm like wait a minute wait a
minute we can't get sued no no it's on
the manufacturer oh can you give me that
in writing my business manager's on the
phone I want this to be legit all right
so you and Ian have been friends for
many many years you still have this
friendship
um you have this bourbon uh it's yeah
it's incredible you talk how often oh my
god dude I mean it's a full-time job
it's like it's it's absolutely insane I
mean every day emails threads uh text
messages we have employees we have um
you know we have an office we have um I
mean where's your office every single
day we have well Ian and I have like a
little office in Malibu actually that we
share it's just like our little Studio
we'll we'll do
um you know taste things or zooms and
things of that nature and you know but
then our our most of our our team is in
Texas and believe it or not Canada but
um man it's a whole thing it started out
as this covid project we were like hey
let's just make a bourbon well we talked
about it you I don't know if you ever
saw Vampire Diaries but all we did was
drink bourbon I mean it was like a thing
it was like so we wanted to do it
Brothers it makes perfect sense well
that by the way so all the fans would
say like you know when when we would do
these like conventions or something they
would say like you know why don't you
guys have a bourbon why don't you guys
have a bourbon and uh so many years they
were saying that we kept saying why
aren't we doing this and we finally did
it so it was like one of those things we
didn't talk about it forever we've been
drinking bourbon forever you know we
shot in the South wow we shot the pilot
in Vancouver and then we moved the
series to Atlanta right to Atlanta all
bourbon down there I love it so I love
it well look there's tons of stuff I
mean you went on to direct and Purdue
she directed an episode directed like
Shadowhunters you had a four television
show deal with Warner Brothers yeah yeah
you have you do all these things do you
still like look protestorially is that
your thing like you want to More Produce
and create do you still love acting or
you just want to do it all yeah it's
funny I mean
it's uh when a great role comes around
like right now I'm doing Star Trek James
T Paramount series strange new worlds
it's just that's a lot of work isn't it
I'll be on man is it hard do you like
are you were you nervous because it's
only done one season right it's only
done uh yes it's only done one season we
Shot season two it hasn't aired yet how
well is it going well I'll tell you I I
could not ask for a better cast I mean
these people and and again I'm not a
series regular right so I come in I'm a
recurring and they welcome me with open
arms they are so awesome the showrunner
uh uh Akiva goldsmen is just the best I
just adore him and Henry Alonzo Myers
um and they're just like the nicest and
Anson Mount who's the lead I love
answering I just had yeah I've had
Amazon before but I want to have them
again he's just he's just such a good
dude yeah he's really I mean Ethan Peck
who plays Spock is such he's a good
friend friend of mine I gotta watch this
I actually want to watch this great show
and it's really interesting we play with
timeline so we haven't actually met
James T Kirk in in his real like we we
met an alternate version of James Seeker
we haven't met James C Kirk um as we
know him and from the original series
which we are uh which we will in season
two and um you know I just uh it's
daunting I've gotten to know William
Shatner he talked to him about the role
and everything yeah yeah yeah what do
you say like congratulations you're
playing this right well it's funny and I
said this story I've I've told this
story before I hope Spock doesn't hit
you like he hated me the most bizarre
bizarre thing happened so I shot the
first episode of Star Trek they told me
they haven't announced that they hadn't
announced that I got cast and they said
don't tell anyone whatever you don't
tell anyone I said okay cool I won't I'm
uh I I'm flying from Chicago to LA
and get on the plane and I and I had
just binged every episode of the
original series I've watched it as well
right so I and I look up and I'm like
is that I get on the plane I'm like is
that William Shatner I was like this
can't be and he had just gotten back
from space with Bezos and I guarantee he
was reading a book uh yeah I think he
was always yeah he was reading a book so
but but but anyway so I get on the plane
and I look and I see the seat next to
him is empty I look at my ticket and I
and it's I'm I'm the seat next to him
and I'm like this is this is just like
me well is this is this a candid camera
right he's just like you know Paramount
did something and it's like set up and
it's you know you've got something you
can say yeah not just small talk it's
like I just want to let you know I'm a
big fan and also I'm playing the new
well so I sit on the I get on the plane
I start I'm so fidgety and I we had
actually met spoken on the phone before
because we were neighbors and there was
something and I was like oh I don't know
I'm Paul Wesley I don't know if you you
remember he was like oh yeah right
uh-huh but kind of like it was just like
reading his book as you said right right
and doing a thing I didn't want to
bother him ever people even some woman
was trying to take photos of him and
anyway and we're flying and I'm like
trying to allude to the fact that I'm
playing this role without saying it and
I honestly think he thought I was like
some deranged like I yeah and some like
making I was stuttering I was just in
between you know it was just it was a
disaster I asked him for a selfie and he
was um he was kind enough to to do it I
felt terrible but I said I gotta capture
this moment anyway I get the part uh I
mean I I it's announced that I got the
part and then he you know went on
Twitter and just like tweeted me like
the sweetest thing you know there's just
like this this this this
supportive tweet and just said take care
of my ship you know and it was just like
it was such a beautiful moment and but
but it was like I felt redeemed because
I I really for the for those few months
thought you know he thinks I'm this
deranged lunatic who's like a hardcore
Trekkie who couldn't find his words and
then so when he tweeted me I was pretty
thrilled and then I saw him and they
invited me to do um uh give a give an
opening uh talk at his hand print
ceremony in San Diego a Comic-Con really
went over there and we chatted for a
while and he was so lovely and how many
people have played James T Kirk besides
him um on television just him so you're
the only one uh other than Chris Pine in
the in the movie in the movie right yeah
yes but
is there some kind of thing where you're
like I need to talk like this a little
bit it's fine I thought should I I had a
conversation with the I had a
conversation with the show Runners and
it was they was they you know they very
specifically said do not do an imitation
of of of the original you know and it's
just you know we kind of laughed about
it but I I wouldn't want to I wouldn't
do that anyway I just felt like um and
by the way I mean I watched the series
and I do think that there's this um
stigma uh that you know that is slightly
exaggerated absolutely you know because
if you watch the series he's actually
he's actually pretty and it's cool very
much so and then and then in the um yeah
he's cool he's smooth he's very charming
and it's just like it's pretty
effortless if you watch the original it
is I love the original I really love it
I think there were 78 episodes yeah yeah
I'm not sure it was a double episode
there was uh it was the one when the
wrathicon guy what was his name oh uh
old school I met yeah yeah it was his
name he was uh Fantasy Island yeah yeah
his name Ryan Fantasy Island lead guy uh
um the plain boss and he goes it's uh no
I have it I have his name
everybody's saying it right now I don't
want to do without it's like a long name
no I know I know it's like
[Music]
Montel Montel Montague
Ricardo Montalban yeah there you go yeah
yeah I met him once and I go oh I'm a
huge fan he was older he was in a
wheelchair it was at this restaurant
um and you know there's no one there
except him and whoever he was with and I
it's like oh my God he's like oh thank
you nice to me oh that's awesome he was
really sweet that's awesome that's
always nice when you're kind of the
people that you look into you're like oh
my God you grew up with yeah and they're
kind yeah this is called [__] talking
with uh Paul Wesley this is rapid fire
these are my top tier patrons they're
gonna fire stuff out you can rap and
fire them just quick answers uh go to
inside of you uh it's like a Meisner
class yeah right yeah
patreon.com inside of you become a
patron support the podcast without
patrons I couldn't do this here we go
Ashley R when you and Ian did Vampire
Diaries did you know each other had been
on Smallville both have been on
Smallville uh no
he was on Smallville I knew I know that
now but I didn't know it at the time you
mean now today no I know it now yeah
how was he he's great yeah yeah would
you would you talk much about anything
that would you do you think you talked
about no no oh when I talked to me like
if you oh yeah if he was a dick and I
remembered him being an [__] I'd
probably go yeah
he was very into his work yeah but you
know uh what I do know is this I saw him
years later and he was a dick no he
wouldn't have been a greater Guy The Man
He's become is just like yeah like we're
all young we're all doing our thing I
didn't know him and he was nice and yeah
they go by fast yeah yeah you come in
you go you know you leave I barely had
anything with him maybe one scene and he
was really cool no but then I met him
and we talked for a while and I was like
this guy's cool he's a great guy he
gives he's charitable you know he had
the same lawyer nice Lei Lonnie makes
Todd yeah Rubenstein I love yours too no
but I love him Todd's the best he is the
best on Smallville your credit is Paul
wasilowskiwski was it your idea to
professionally change your name or your
agents side note love your bourbon love
your suit
Sansa Lambs I love it I love that moment
I love you
um
uh my idea I wanted to change it because
my real last name is vashilevsky and the
Americanized pronunciation wasilwski was
driving me crazy so I wanted it to start
with a W and end with an e and I like
literally arbitrarily chose uh Wesley
you know if you're a hockey player you
could keep it I know
yeah over little mu back to my channel
by the way what's that one actress Mia
wasikowska or something like that yeah I
know who you're talking about it yeah I
know she made it work she should have
changed it yeah Jessica oh Benjamin J
congratulations I've been cast as the
new James T Kirk can you leave anything
for the second season tease anything
about the second season of strange new
worlds uh can I tease anything I mean I
I guess I can tease the fact that um
we will meet Kirk as we know him in the
the the time frame and in the Canon that
we know from the Original Series yeah
yeah because we have yet that's exciting
yeah I think that will get more of yours
yeah that they know that there you go
you're smart you're smart man Jessica B
where is your happy place nature nature
I just said the answer to that yeah
thanks uh Raj walk me through your
typical morning routine working on a TV
film
as quick as you can like what do you do
you wake up obviously oh on a TV series
yeah yeah you wake up hopefully
um I hope wake up hopefully not too late
um no you're getting hair and makeup
these guys know how it is get in hair
and makeup uh which you know if you're
Ian Somerhalder takes three hours uh if
Paul Wesley takes 15 minutes but do you
do any kind of routine like working out
meditation Man by Seasons
That's why I said no shirtless scenes
I'm not working I can barely even get
out of bed uh but yeah season one two
you're working out you're doing the diet
you're doing this you're that you know
all that all that [__] you wake up you
go read the scene oh my God you come
back finish they call you in you do the
scene that's right you always block it
and then you always get what two to
three takes on a on a network show and
then you gotta move on you don't have
time
um cable series I'm sure you can do
plenty more I hope yeah Marisol P what
would be the role of a lifetime for you
James T Kirk um James C Kirk frankly I
know I'm not kidding uh one of the most
iconic TV characters in the history of
Television if not the most iconic and
true and uh to to be able to step in
those shoes is uh you know beyond
um uh you know for me and an honor yeah
Nathan J I wanted to say thank you sorry
I keep you doing that my friend whiskey
love my friend Whitney whiskey because
I'm doing the bourbon thing my friend
Whitney loved Vampire Diaries it was her
favorite show of all time she sadly
passed in 2020 but she went to a Grave
Loving Stefan and Stefan Stefan Stefan
Stefan and Damon so thank you a million
times for giving her an hour of Peace
each week for eight years wow Jesus
thank you that is uh you know when I
hear that uh and I've heard that first
of all it's so beautifully said Thank
you for telling me that but um you know
when I hear these things which I don't
know if you do any of these fan
conventions and these things I I get
that a lot um people will tell me their
story they get through something or hey
you know I was really sick for x amount
of you know months and I watched your
show and it helped me feel less lonely
and I am just uh always I forget the
power of Television I forget how
powerful it is so you know when you have
your work affect someone in a positive
way
um and I'm so sorry for your loss but um
I'm glad that I was able to you know be
a part of that um happiness while she
was here well said yeah it's something
that when you hear it's just like you
can't believe it like really yeah this
showed it yeah you know it's a cool
thing yeah lastly have you you ever deal
with anxiety or depression you ever go
through that yeah dude you do oh my God
because we talk about that a lot on the
show and I always deal with it we both
try and go to therapy I go to therapy
money to listeners I'm my head was
spinning last night I didn't sleep I I
slept for for a few hours but I'm a
little out of it today because my head I
over analyze things I get anxiety I
start thinking about stuff and I'm a
generally very happy guy but for
whatever reason my head spins I get a
ton of anxiety it's something I
inherited from you know my mom who's
very anxious you know how that is oh my
God and a lot of it too is like you know
you can have
um you know your genes can literally be
affected through trauma of your
ancestors so who knows you know I don't
know if if your family's been to
anything but just even the war my
family's been through the war in in
World War 2 and I'm sure I've inherited
some anxiety from you know my my
grandparents and great grandparents so
um yeah manic depressive depression all
that stuff can be and I believe you know
my mom definitely gave me a lot of that
yeah yeah yeah and you know it's just
something that I try to deal with but I
think openly talking about it not being
ashamed of it and saying yeah I get a
ton of anxiety I get depressed all the
time if you go to therapy um yeah in
fact I'm going to therapy after this
podcast what time is it well I'm not
gonna go yeah it's just it's just like
we're gonna do a zoom that's gonna get
back yeah I think it's important to be
consistent oh yeah I love therapy I I
think it's just so important better help
is one of our sponsors by the way and
it's just like everyone uses it yeah
like because it's you know it's like I'm
just just try it I think people want to
tear meditation is very helpful too yeah
uh uh yeah therapy finding a good
therapist
um talking you know just being open what
do you think your lowest point in your
life was where you were just like so
down that you didn't you could turn it
around but you did somehow yeah
um oh man it was actually
um probably season
Believe It or Not season two of The
Vampire Diaries which was a huge hit
show everything was great and I fell
into this like crazy depression crazy
you know why
it was a series of events that led to
that
um some personal things and I just uh
man I was in such a hole that my parents
had to like fly out to like check on me
that's how bad it was yeah but I got out
of it man
I gotta that's that's the thing you have
to see a light like I always tell people
who are like you know even like if you
do like a cameo or something like that I
would have been like my friends in deep
depression and you know can't get out
I'm like listen yeah you're 30. yeah
right I'm 50. yeah you've got a lot of
life and it's called life yeah you're
gonna have the lowest of lows everyone
has it man I was like 29 or whatever 28
I don't even know I was 28 years old and
I literally was having a hard time
um uh finding a reason to get out of bed
and I was on a show I was like you know
quote unquote famous I had money I was
on this thing and I was just like why am
I alive that's I was in a depression for
whatever reason
um and then just it just I snapped out
of it and now I look back at it and I go
oh man like if I only knew then what I
know now you know and it was just this
random depression I'm glad you got out
of it thank you yeah I've been there too
you know we had a guest out one rich and
remember
I had no idea but he started opening up
and I said so have you ever been that
low he goes oh yeah he's got kids and a
wife and he had just gotten so depressed
that he went in his attic or something
and he tried to hang himself oh wow and
he actually hung himself and he says
thank God that I was strong enough I he
goes when they say you see your life
pass before you wow is real wow my whole
life passed before me and I somehow had
the strength myself out of the whatever
you know oh yeah yeah and that was just
like it scares me even more because I
don't think I'm strong enough yeah well
don't no no don't don't don't think I do
it that's it you know but no no God
forbid no no but it's like you know
people opening up about that stuff and
by the way Greg's been great yeah isn't
he fantastic how is he doing what's he
doing great he's just chilling though
this has been great yeah man I only you
got here a little late so that's why we
went a little over but it's only I don't
know I don't mind I don't mind not at
all right I was making sure are we are
we good at all yeah this is great this
is so good yeah man it was so easy to
talk to you thank you I feel like you
know I never we never knew each other
go [__] yourself thank you yeah this has
been a fantastic ride I hope you come
back on sometime and you know I'd love
to I'd love if you took I said hey come
on a hike it's only like an hour hour
and a half yeah man come with me I'll
show you some cool places I will if you
do that I will do it and bring your dog
yeah I'll bring Blanche maybe not the
pups don't bring the pup no that could
be a pain in the ass yeah yeah you'll
end up carrying the pup but bring
Blanche you don't want to do that no
thanks for coming thanks man thanks for
having me
good dude good dude really solid solid
dude I was he was just it was I didn't
know because it's been so many years and
he had big Fame he's got a big following
you don't know how people are gonna
react and he just feels like he's
unfazed uh maybe he was uh more phased
when he was younger
um but now just uh seems like he's got
it going on and uh like that song
like a lot of songs some things mom has
got it going on Stacy's mom Stacy's Mom
so if you look if you're here for Paul
Wesley and you really enjoyed the
interview I hope you did uh please
subscribe listen to the podcast uh even
if you don't know every guest you'll
learn something from each guest I do it
helps me with my anxiety and I learned
so much from these so thank you and of
course patreon.com if you want or slash
inside of you patreon.comcity if you
want to join patreon and help the
podcast without my patrons I wouldn't be
here I mean I'd be here but I wouldn't
be here on the podcast does that make
sense Ryan yes it does somehow let's
give out
the top tier names okay this is the
patron shout outs one of my favorite
moments I'm gonna look at it this time
yeah maybe you should read out some
names I could do that we can trade off
like yeah why don't we do it Nancy D
Leah and Kristen little Lisa you Kiko
Jill e Brian H Nico p
Robert B Jason W Sophie M Mirage C
Joshua D Jennifer N what if I do a voice
then you have to match it okay
Stacy L Jamal F gymnasty Odon Supremo 99
Mall Santiago M Chad W Liam p
mm-hmm
Maddie s
Belinda n Dave H shilaji Brad D or honey
it's not matching my voice you're not
rolling here's ours well I was trying to
do it but then it came Tabitha T and Tom
and Talia M all right here we go
Betsy D Angel M real and C Cory K def
Nixon
Michelle a Jeremy C
Brandy D Joey m
Eugene
and Leah
Curry
cake B Angela F male s
Christine s Christine s Erica Eric H
Shane R Andrew M
I'm turning to something else Amanda R
Jen B Stephanie K and jewelry
Luna R Mike F Stone Age Brian ew
[Music]
Jessica B Kyle f
it's kind of Napoleon isn't it no no
I'll do him next
Kyle F Marisol P Kaylee J Mickey L Bryan
a
Ashley F
Marianne Louise L gosh
Romeo B
Veronica Q
Frank B
gen T Nikki L gosh Ellen H April r
Cassie B derrigan
JD that's not it jdw Michelle oh how did
Ryan do folks you let us know medium uh
we love you thanks for uh tuning in
we'll see you uh oh from the Hollywood
Hills in California I'm Michael
Rosenbaum I'm Ryan Deus a little wave to
the camera we love you guys be good to
yourself we'll see you
[Music]